our next guest you saw him earlier in
the hour at the podium and see him
tomorrow on that the bench press Derrick
brown Auburn defensive lineman Josh
Norris was here he's got Derrick brown
peg number four overall to the New York
Giants so get ready to have your name
called early when the draft begins
they're great to see you how's the week
going for you so far
good you know just come in be able to
you know do what was asked of us and you
know sit down you know kind of talk to
that with these guys you know a lot of
these guys and stuff from recruiting so
it's gonna kind of fun what's been the
toughest part of this week for you I
think that has been toughest part you
know just I'm used to being on the top
schedule and being on the strict
schedules so you know that's what that's
what it is the one thing that I can't
imagine doing is the medical not going
through the tests but just sitting
around and waiting and waiting what was
that experience like for you like I said
we got a bunch of catches in the lion
group so you know hey when it's bad
people thought it was you know we just
came in here with high attitude you know
you know just sending a thing about
everything and just saying you know all
right that's what we're gonna do we're
gonna take care of business week how
much of the testosterone takes over when
you guys get together the first time and
you're looking who's bigger than who who
could take who and and that kind of
stuff does any of that bubble up when
you first meet these guys no you know
goofy in their own way like I say you
know I've known these guys I was I was
16 17 years old in high school and you
know guys you know watch each other play
college football when did you know that
you were gonna have the skills to be an
NFL caliber player um you know I felt I
always had a chance to you know when I
first even when I got my first high
offer in high school I was kind of like
this is what it's gonna be take care of
my family one day and you know I just
turned my mom said of that and you know
try to focus in on that when did you
have your growth spurt to get to the
size that you're at now 6 for 326 I was
eighth grade I grew a shot up in the
summertime like 4 inches who is it that
you can remember dominating the most
during your college career who was the
guy that you just put right into the
ground
I can't even remember what's that I
can't remember how about the Alabama
game good performance there why did it
go so easily for you getting such a good
team
I don't know necessary one easy I
actually think that's probably one of
the games where you know I didn't really
have is as much as I would like to have
coming out of me there in that game so
you know
how much do you think playing in the SEC
has you prepared to thrive at the NFL
because you're seeing a lot of guys
there they're gonna be in the NFL it's
NFL stadiums it's loud it's crazy that's
got to make it easier than it would be
if you were at a smaller school yeah I
mean this is the third conference of the
league so you know it's one of those
things where you know going against the
top-tier talent every single week it's
just been it's been exciting and you
know eventful for us high school where'd
you go Lanier High School Sugar Hill
Georgia all right we got some Sugar Hill
Georgia McNear high school highlights of
Derek Brown and I it's usually easy to
pick up but man that that looked like it
was painful for the guy on the other end
of it it's amazing how the elite players
how much it jumps out when you watch the
highlights of how good you were
did it ever feel like like it was too
easy for you at the high school level
not only so I think sophomore year was
kind of a wake-up oh there you go
there's that a fun where is that a pick
six that's big see all right bounce off
with running backs in right there yeah
you know and you don't forget moments
like that one would you would you do
when you wait you probably restricted in
what you do to celebrate in high school
what you do when you scored I just yet
above every turn around what about
sideline you ever want to play offense
not on the offensive line always want to
be you know I played in high school I
got into played like Wildcat quarterback
up back caught touchdown passes you know
all the fun stuff you know we see we see
plenty of guys who make their way from
defensive line into the backfield or at
tight end you know we start planting the
seed now with some of these coaches that
maybe that's something you could do it
sounds like you've got you've got the
the athleticism to pull it off yeah I do
but I want to rush the passer for a long
time so I think you know I'm trying to
stick to you who do you want to sack the
most at the NFL level
I don't even know to be honest you know
I knew once I won the top guys and you
also got quarterback from high from
college planning the league so you know
that'll be fun
who's the guy that when you show up on
an NFL field in an NFL uniform for the
first time and you see him out there
you're gonna say I can't believe I'm on
the same field as this guy you know a
lot of guns a lot of top-notch defensive
linemen watching my whole life kind of
start over now you kind of make it can't
be like that yeah I'd be like man right
it's gonna be it's gonna be crazy to see
his opportunity who do you see in the
league now that you you think you can
play like that guy I say flexor Cox you
know sit down watch a lot of this tape
they didn't say much cause Chris Jones
all those guys be able to sit there and
watch the tape you know Aaron Donald
Thomas you know not only for power but
you know being able to watch them and
you know kind of get the finesse moves
and see if you know you're gonna
implementing that in your game any of
the guys currently in the league working
with you directly helping you out to get
yourself ready for what you're gonna be
facing when you join an NFL team I know
you know I just got to said I got talked
to a couple of and you know just kind of
chatted up with him for a little while
and kind of you know I have some
questions as well I you know what do you
do when it's not time to play football
what's your what's your favorite thing
to do when you're away from the field
I'm a dad so not fair then do is
whatever my son wants to do how would
your boy warned he said I assume he's
getting into all sorts of things walking
around running around yeah he just
started walking so and now we got a
whole new block everything so all kind
is a lot of everything how much do you
think the experience of being a dad and
the maturity that you necessarily go
through how much do you think that's
prepared you for kind of what you're
going through now and the maturity you
need to be ready to do everything they
expect to be here the patience you need
to show and and all the boxes you have
to check to get yourself ready to be
drafted I know the patience is something
you learn you know my son you know
you're not the most cooperative so you
know it's kind of one of those things
you know he's a baby so he didn't you
never really care about what you want or
what you need so sleep isn't something I
got a lot of in the first year of his
life but you know just little things
like that you know I mean you look at it
but you know I cherish my kid more than
anything well and it's it's great that
you've had that experience because I do
think it helps guys
and it gets you to the point where you
can reach your potential faster in the
NFL because you're ready for the mental
challenge and you seem to be ready for
everything that is gonna come your way
no matter how big or strong the guy is
across from you give me a give me a
quick scouting report on Jill burrow
laser focus guy you know in our game we
were trying to lay the wood to him and
you know hit him he just kept popping up
popping up popping up you know
eventually these core bats takes him in
he's like that and going and so on y'all
gotta find somebody else to do what they
do or less you know it's all gonna be
frantic and high balls man's poised
who's the best quarterback you've seen
so far I paused a jobber oh yeah second
best
how about 2i you propose you get it get
it and go that's what is yeah and you
know the mobility is so important now
too and that makes it harder as a pass
rusher because the guys not just in the
pocket you got to be able to to chase
him around and get out on the edge work
on the cardio a little bit so you can
keep up with these guys
thank you in my freshman year generates
you know a lot of times you don't you
know a lot of guys you don't really know
but I mean he wouldn't Ellis you and
beat them so you know a freshman year
all right Derek brown stay tuned for the
April draft will be one of the first
names called we appreciate some of your
time
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports